hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain a science fiction action film
called district 9.
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the film opens with a
style series of interviews that
introduce the story
twenty years ago in 1982 a giant
extraterrestrial spaceship had arrived
above johannesburg south africa
humankind was shocked because it was the
first instance of an alien species
visiting them
however as the humans waited for aliens
to come out the ship hovered over the
city for three months with no sign of
life
eventually humans took the initiative
and cut into the ship to investigate
what was inside they were surprised to
have discovered a large group of aliens
who were malnourished and sick
more than a million aliens were given
permission to leave their craft and live
on earth
the government of south africa relocated
them to a terrestrial camp for their
safety they were housed in a swallowed
government camp in johannesburg
consisting mostly of rusty looking one
to two room shacks
however over the years the camp turned
into a slum because of overcrowding and
militarization
currently the place is known as district
9.
it is now 20 years later since the ship
landed and the aliens have repopulated
into 1.8 million of them they cannot go
back to their planet because during the
landing a command module had fallen into
the earth's surface and was never found
hence the giant extraterrestrial
spaceship is still hovering above the
city but is inoperable stuck in the slum
for two decades the aliens have
formulated their own lifestyle they
started to ransack the nearest pile of
garbage for food the aliens had no sense
of ownership so they burned and
destroyed cars and other human
properties
on top of that the slum was heavily
armed as a nigerian black market sold
human weapons to aliens at a high price
a massive black market is set up between
the aliens and a nigerian gang of
criminals led by a half-paralyzed
psychopathic man named obi sancho
obesanjo's gang sold to them canned cat
food which happens to be liked by the
aliens in addition inner species
prostitution was also encouraged
the aliens have learned to speak and
understand english and are good at
communicating with humans
however they do not possess any
leadership qualities or functions
it is later assumed that a plague may
have wiped out all of the leadership
cast soon the nigerians start to get fed
up with the aliens
after 20 years they have put up signs in
the park and shops banning them from
entering a derogatory term prawn comes
into fashion referring to the bottom
feeding sea creature they resemble
humans begin to riot and protest to
remove the prawns from johannesburg the
locals begin to complain that the
government is wasting too much money on
this filthy creature the aliens are
being called ignorant lawbreakers who
bleed resources from humans
patience over the alien situation among
the people of johannesburg has run out
following the dispute between the aliens
and locals the government hires
multinational united mnu a private
weapons manufacturer company that shows
little regard for the aliens welfare the
aliens also have weaponry of their own
which are engineered in a biological
manner making them unusable for humans
the mnu does research on such alien
ammunition
the mnu is tasked to relocate the aliens
from district 9 to a new camp outside
the city an mnu field operative named
wikis van der mereva is made the
commander of the mission wikis and a
team of soldiers are sent to district 9
to make the prawns sign a contract of
evacuation
with his assistant and a soldier wikis
goes house to house in district nine
they also shoot and kill some of the
uncooperative aliens
then they come across a house with alien
eggs and set it on fire
meanwhile three aliens christopher
johnson his young son cj and
christopher's friend search a garbage
dump for alien fuel
christopher has been working to
synthesize a liquid for the past 20
years and is finally successful however
just then wikis and his team arrive at
his front door christopher's friend goes
to see wikis as christopher hides the
liquid in the house and runs away
through the back door
wikis and his team go inside the house
to search for weapons where they find
the liquid while inspecting it wikis
accidentally sprays it on his face after
composing himself he puts the liquid in
a bag to send it to the lab later
christopher's friend starts to attack
wikis so his team is shot dead by the
soldiers
wikis arm is injured in the fight so his
assistant dresses it
soon he starts feeling uncomfortable and
sick he vomits while inspecting
christopher's home
his team takes him to a nearby
restaurant where his nose secretes a
black fluid they start worrying for him
and take him back to the mnu
headquarters wikis cannot stop coughing
and feels dizzy his fingernails start to
decay and fall off
back at district 9 christopher and his
son desperately search for the liquid
they had hidden
that day wikis comes home to a surprise
party as he is about to cut the cake he
vomits black substance all over it the
guests are disgusted his wife takes him
to the doctor he undoes the dressing
from his arms and is horrified to see it
as changed into an alien claw wikkus
panics and starts yelling as the doctor
tries to calm him down the doctor then
calls the security and restrains whiskus
they put him in a body bag and take him
to the menu lab they find out that he is
turning into an alien because of the
liquid that was splashed onto his face
that day they also find the liquid in
his pocket the doctors performed several
experiments on him it turns out that
whiskis can use the alien weapon that no
humans can they even make him shoot an
innocent prawn as he begs them to leave
the guy the scientists discover that his
dna is currently in balance with the
alien dna which is gradually
transforming him completely into a prawn
with the permission of wikis ruthless
father-in-law they decide to harvest his
body for biological material at this
critical point and sell them to the
organizations and governments who are
keen on biotechnology
however as they are about to perform the
procedures on him he manages to break
free and overpower his captors he then
flees from the mnu headquarters and ends
up in his home
but the mnu agents are already there
looking for him he goes to a nearby
restaurant where he sees himself on the
news
it is falsely reported that he has had
prolonged sexual intercourse with a
prawn making him turn into one of them
the news also claims that his disease is
contagious and warns people to stay 20
feet away if they come across him with
nowhere to go he takes refuge in
district 9.
wikis ends up in christopher's shed
where he finds that christopher has
hidden the spaceship's command module
that had disappeared years ago the
liquid he prepared was the fuel to
activate the ship again so they could go
back to their planet the same fuel can
help wikis turn back to humans
so the two prepare to go to the mnu
headquarters to bring back the liquid
wikis goes to the gang leader ob sanjo
to buy some weapons for their quest
however obesanjo wants to cut off
wikis's alien arm to eat it the
nigerians believe that eating alien body
parts will get rid of diseases according
to a concept called muddy before they
can cut his arms wikis gets his hands on
an alien weapon and attacks the gang
with the help of it he collects all
other weapons and flees from there
christopher and wikis then attacked the
mnu headquarters because of the weapons
they managed to wipe out most of the lab
within minutes the colonel who is in
charge of mnu's security and has been
tasked to capture wikis arrives with his
squad wikis finally finds the liquid but
just then christopher finds his fellow
alien in the lab
he had been experimented upon by humans
the soldiers get inside the lab and
start firing at them
the two beat the walls and managed to
flee from there however the police
chopper follows their car to district
nine
christopher and wikis are now in his
shed where christopher reveals that he
has to save his people first only then
he will transform wikis agitated wikis
hits him with a log and knocks him out
he then powers up the ship himself
wikis gets in it and flies the ship
while the whole world watches in awe
however when the craft is mid-air it is
knocked out by an mnu missile the
soldiers arrest wikis from inside the
ship while christopher's son cj hides
just then the soldiers are attacked by
obesanjo and his men
after an intense fight between them
wikis is captured by obi sanjo
obi sanjo is about to cut off wikis arm
to eat it but is stopped when little cj
activates an automated gun and fires at
them as wikis escapes the mother ship
that had been dormant for all these
years starts moving
wikis then gets to the huge automated
battle suit and starts controlling it he
initially plans to run away using it but
then comes back to rescue christopher
the two start running towards the
spacecraft but the battle suit is shot
midway and stops working
wikis insists christopher go save his
son in the other prawns christopher
promises him that he will be back in
three years and turn wikis back to
normal
wikis distracts the soldiers as
christopher takes his son and starts the
mother ship
it rises in the sky and finally attaches
to the spacecraft
below an injured wikis is arrested by
the colonel who is about to kill him
however the other prawns stand up for
wikis they circle the kernel and rip his
head off
the massive spaceship finally takes off
with christopher and his son in it as
the whole world watches in awe
people speculate that christopher will
come back for the rescue mission to save
all of his kinds
wikis has disappeared completely after
the incident and no one knows his
whereabouts the prawn relocating mission
was successful
currently they live in district 10 which
lies 200 kilometers outside of
johannesburg and their population has
increased to 2.5 million
then we see footage of wikis wife
holding a metal flower which she claimed
she had found at her doorstep
she believes that wikis put it there and
still has hopes of him being alive
the movie ends as we see a now fully
transformed wikis in a junkyard crafting
a metal rose for his wife
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching